[Applaudissements]
directement mon poste merci d'être avec
nous dans un instant à stéphane
rotenberg qui viendra nous rejoindre on
aura également à l'ex fis il viendra
également part à pékin express on
l'enverra quelqu'un dans la rue a arrêté
une personne qui passera par ici
il lui demandera s'il a vu qui bien sûr
vous le saurez dans un instant si je
pense que vous avez déjà la réponse chez
vous alors ça twitter actuellement ya un
aymeric qui nous dit dégueulasse les
airs swinnen ringards les 4 alors oui
gilles verdez effet le je me suis remis
en question car clairement on dirait le
doc dans retour vers le futur
c'est vrai c'est pas mal je sais c'est
pas réussi mais c'est mieux c'est
beaucoup mieux